the strength of a nation's currency is
based on the strength of that nation's
economy
and the american economy is by far the
strongest in the world
accordingly i have directed the
secretary of the treasury to take the
action necessary
to defend the dollar against the
speculators
i have directed secretary conley to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar
into gold or other reserve assets
except in amounts and conditions
determined to be in the interest of
monetary stability
and in the best interest of the united
states
august 15 1971 will stand as an
important event in economic history
for many many generations
in fact you know hundreds of years from
now people will look back to that day
[Music]
[Music]
the sun rises today as it has a million
times before
commuters wake up and travel to their
offices to begin the day's work
farmers tend to their crops construction
workers
build new infrastructure today is a day
like any other
or is it in 2008 the world experienced
one of the greatest financial turmoils
in history
markets around the world started
crashing and major financial
institutions
once thought to be invincible started
showing signs of collapse
governments responded quickly issuing
massive bailouts and stimulus packages
in an effort to keep the world economy
afloat
and it worked the global economy
recovered much quicker than most
predicted
and soon it was back to business as
usual
and yet something still isn't quite
right
a growing sense of unease fills the
population
in the world of finance indeed in all
facets of modern life cracks have
started to appear
there's angst out there and i think if
you talk to people on the street today
they would tell you i don't know what's
causing all this
but this just doesn't feel normal to me
you know the government's running a
trillion dollars worth of deficit why
isn't the economy improving
the government's gonna spend almost 3.7
trillion dollars
why don't i have a job why why is the
unemployment rate
at nine percent and i even think that
number's understated
a lot of people are feeling unsure about
the world today
concerned that something terrible is
waiting in the wings
we're told that the global financial
crisis of a few years ago has been fixed
but what if the crisis isn't the cause
of the angst so many of us feel
but rather the symptom of a much deeper
problem
[Music]
at bretton woods new hampshire delegates
from 44 allied and associate countries
arrive for the opening of the united
nations monetary and financial
conference
our story begins in 1944
with world war ii coming to an end the
allied nations met at bretton woods new
hampshire to create a new financial
system which would stabilize the world
once the war ended
with america poised to enter a golden
age of prosperity
the us dollar was chosen as the world's
reserve currency
the bretton wood system was created
after the second world war at the
bretton woods conference in new
hampshire
and rather than using gold as the means
of exchange between
countries as was the case under the old
gold standard
the dollar was going to be used and the
dollar was chosen because back then it
was as good as gold
under this new system countries agreed
to fix their currencies to the u.s
dollar
and the u.s dollar would be tied to gold
at a price of 35 dollars per ounce
this meant that countries around the
world could trade their currencies for
us dollars
which they could then exchange for gold
this created a system where all
currencies were essentially
backed by gold to avoid the logistics of
shipping
physical gold across the world when
countries did exchange their currencies
for gold
it was usually stored safely in the u.s
[Music]
under the brenton woods system you could
exchange
your currency or your dollars for gold
now only applied to
foreign countries and central banks and
we began to run budget deficits we were
running the great society program under
lyndon johnson we were fighting a war
in vietnam and all of a sudden we were
running these deficits and countries
were
changing their dollars and they said
they wanted gold and it began with the
french and then it started to spread
with all the new spending programs in
the united states
other countries became concerned that
the u.s was spending more money than it
had
gold reserves they started exchanging
their dollars for gold
and demanded physical delivery as they
felt that there were more dollars being
printed
than the gold that backed it to prevent
this outflow of gold from american
vaults
president nixon called for an emergency
suspension of the gold convertibility
system
i have directed the secretary of the
treasury to take the action necessary
to defend the dollar against the
speculators
i have directed secretary connelly to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar
into gold or other reserve assets all of
the problems that we see today in the
monetary system
are a direct result of the decision made
in
august 15 1971 you know to abandon
a fixed link back to gold what gold did
is it provided discipline on governments
provided discipline on government
spending under the old
system if you ran a budget deficit then
what would happen
is gold would flow out of your country
until there was a balance again
well without any gold backing then
countries ran perpetual deficits so if
you look at
for example this country from 1971 on
the us has never run
a surplus ever since we went off the
gold standard it's just been perpetual
stimulus
good times bad times always run a
deficit
what led nixon to abandon the gold
standard in 1971
and although he claimed it was temporary
we've been waiting 40 years
we're still off of it we ran up huge
deficits
during the 1960s we had the guns
and butter economy where the government
was both simultaneously fighting a war
in vietnam abroad
in addition we were funding manned
missions uh to the moon in the whole
space program
we were creating more money than we had
gold reserves to back it up
and a lot of our foreign creditors saw
this
and began to demand gold rather than
their federal reserve notes because they
sensed that washington simply didn't
have enough gold
to make its commitment to back the
dollar
by removing the link between gold and
the u.s dollar president nixon created a
system where all
currencies were backed by nothing this
is what is known as a fiat currency
fiat currency is currency that's backed
by nothing
except government promises the word fiat
is a latin word
and it basically means currency that's
circulating by force
if people have confidence in that
currency and if there's enough
government force
that will enable the currency to
circulate for a period of time until
people lose confidence
in the currency there is no nation on
this planet that currently uses
money we all use currency there will
come a day
when everybody knows the difference
money is a medium of exchange and the
way it has evolved is that it's always
something of intrinsic
value until the modern age when the
politicians say well we don't need
anything of intrinsic value anymore
all we need is political decree we can
say this is money this piece of paper is
money now money has a new characteristic
but underneath it all there's the same
concept
in place that nobody ever seems to
challenge and that is that governments
have a right to declare
something of of no value to be money and
you must accept it
that's really the problem and it's still
the problem today
it's destroying the economies of the
world
with currencies no longer backed by
anything real or tangible
their value was measured only in
relation to each other
and because countries with relatively
weak currencies can make products
cheaply
countries devalue their own currencies
to make them desirable trading partners
every paper currency measures itself
against the dollar
so if the dollar goes down the other
central banks respond to that
and they try and intervene in the
foreign exchange markets to ensure that
the
impact doesn't hit their domestic
economies
what is a ponzi scheme a ponzi scheme is
a fraudulent investment scheme that
promises high returns for investors with
little or no risk
sounds too good to be true right that's
because it is
in a legitimate investment scheme the
money invested is used to build wealth
typically through low risk ventures like
stock or real estate portfolios
over time this generates enough income
to pay the investor back their initial
investment plus some profit
a ponzi scheme on the other hand
promises massive returns quickly
how does it accomplish this instead of
using the money invested to build wealth
a ponzi scheme simply brings in more
investors to pay off the previous
investors
and because these new investors have
also been promised large returns
the scheme must then find an even bigger
group of investors to pay them off
all the while the creators of the scheme
are skimming cash from each group of
investors
because a ponzi scheme doesn't generate
any wealth itself
it must constantly bring in larger and
larger groups of investors to keep
functioning
eventually no more new investors can be
found
or large numbers of previous investors
all cash out at the same time
and the scheme collapses in on itself by
this time
the perpetrators of the scheme have
siphoned off tremendous amounts of money
for themselves
while the investors are left out of
pocket and out of luck
[Music]
without a fixed link to gold the u.s
treasury has been able to borrow and
spend as much money as it wanted
when the u.s government needs money it
takes out a loan with the federal
reserve
the federal reserve prints the currency
required for the loan
and in return receives an iou from the
u.s treasury
these ious are called government bonds
with the money provided from these loans
or bonds
the u.s government pays its bills and
obligations
meanwhile the u.s treasury and the
federal reserve work
closely together to sell these bonds at
auction where
foreign central banks pension funds and
even
individuals buy these u.s government
loans
and why wouldn't they loaning money to
the u.s government is virtually a
risk-free investment
but if the loans are spent on bills and
paying off
previous loans where does the government
get the money to pay back the current
loan and the interest that is
charged on it is investing in a u.s
government bond simply one small part in
a giant ponzi scheme
the federal reserve system is definitely
a ponzi scheme
there's no question about it they go
through the appearance of lending
money to the governments and the
governments agree
to pay back the money plus interest
and so this money comes into being they
created just for that purpose they give
it to the governments
didn't exist before that you understand
central banks just make it out of
nothing
and click a few keys on a keyboard of a
computer
and the treasury of the united states
government now has another trillion
dollars that it can spend that's where
that money came from
and so that creates a liability on the
part of the federal government to pay it
back plus interest now think about that
plus interest
well when it comes time to pay it back
plus the interest
they can't pay it back and they
certainly can't pay it back plus
interest too
so what they do is they borrow more to
cover the original loan plus the
interest and then
by that time congress wants more money
anyway so
the debt just keeps going up and up and
up and up
under the current monetary system we
borrow all of our currency into
existence and we promise to pay it back
plus interest if you borrow the very
first dollar into existence and that's
the only
dollar that exists on the planet but you
promise to pay it back
plus another dollars worth of interest
where do you get the second dollar
the answer is you have to borrow that
it's a ponzi scheme because
you can never pay it off it always
requires that we go deeper into debt
since 1971 the united states has been
running trade deficits
with the rest of the world meaning we've
been buying a lot more products from the
rest of the world
than they have been buying from us the
japanese and koreans sell us cars and
electronics
the middle east sells us oil and the
chinese
sell us seemingly everything on our
walmart shelves
the u.s pays for these products with u.s
dollars
and everyone is happy but if countries
were to convert these us dollar profits
back into their own currencies
their currencies would rise in value
making their economies less desirable to
trade with
instead countries invest their dollar
profits by buying u.s
government bonds so countries around the
world
sell their goods to the us in exchange
for u.s dollars
which have been borrowed through the
federal reserve creating ious
and countries then loan their us dollar
profits back to the u.s
by buying more ious the money from these
loans
is spent on paying government expenses
as well as paying back
previous ious but in order to do this
larger and larger loans must be made in
order to pay back the principal
and the interest by paying back old
loans
with new and larger loans it would
appear
as if the entire world has been
investing their hard-earned money
into a ponzi scheme of epic proportions
in this business of creating money for
federal governments and
national governments around the world if
they didn't keep creating new money in
larger and larger amounts
the whole thing would crash because this
that's where the money comes from
to pay off the previous loans it's the
new loans
so that's why it's a ponzi scheme it's a
classic ponzi scheme
in order for the us economy to function
we have to borrow more and more money
from the rest of the world
and the more money they loan us today
the more money they have to loan us in
the future
and if they ever stop loaning the whole
thing collapses and we can't pay them
back
every friday night julia's job is to
compare the grocery prices of our
neighborhood stores for
saturday morning shopping there are five
big neighborhood markets within a couple
of blocks of our house
and julia spreads her shopping around
going where the prices are lowest and
the quality best
remember when a chocolate bar cost a
quarter when you could fill your car up
for five dollars and feed a family of
six for thirty five dollars a week
whatever happened to those days without
anything
tangible backing currencies governments
could borrow and print as much currency
as it wanted
this has gradually led to the value of
our currency being eroded
with the creation of all this money that
dilutes the value of all of the dollars
that were out there before
so that the purchasing power of the
dollar gets crowded down down down and
we used to be able to buy a gallon of
gas for you know 31 cents
now it's hitting around five dollars the
average guy in the street is affected by
inflation because of the loss of
purchasing power
and as a consequence his standard of
living is declining if he can't keep up
with the inflation rate
in many measures of a standard of living
americans today are actually worse off
you can take my grandparents my
grandmother never worked
despite the fact that my grandfather was
a carpenter and they had eight children
i could a carpenter somebody without
even a high school diploma
just working in a blue collar job
support a wife and eight kids today
not a chance
[Music]
with inflation rising faster than
incomes
people were forced into more and more
drastic measures to maintain their
standard of living
[Music]
with each new day the work of a family
begins again
we went off gold backing of the dollar
what used to happen prior to that
is the husband went to work the wife
stayed at home raised the family
because of inflation in the 70s the wife
went to work
so now you had two incomes that were
necessary to produce and buy the same
goods and services
in the 90s we stopped saving the savings
rate basically got down to zero because
people were spending they couldn't save
in order to buy the same goods and
services
then we got to the last decade
the wife was already working the savings
were down to zero
they borrowed money and so we've gone
from
two earners getting rid of our savings
rate
to borrowing money to keep pace with
inflation
the average person is now forced to
borrow well beyond their means
getting themselves deeply into debt at
first
this was to maintain a nice standard of
living but slowly
it has become necessary just to survive
by printing so much currency and
devaluing it so heavily
it would seem that governments are
essentially levying a hidden
tax on their people
central banks try to say that two
percent or three percent inflation is a
good thing and they make that
a target well it's still a tax
why is two percent inflation or three
percent inflation
better for the country than no than no
inflation
you will be told of course that's beth
and deflation
and you'll be told that uh people like
to feel that their money
or their jobs or their wages are going
up by two percent at least it's
something
where the fact that two percent is
robbery and
and what they get is going down by that
amount
we are experiencing inflation these days
i mean yeah
they say the cpi's up whatever is two or
three percent i mean anybody who's
alive knows that inflation is well
beyond that
probably running double digits the
purchasing power of the average person
has been deteriorating drastically
but in order to disguise this
governments have been skewing the
figures in their reports
to make it seem as if inflation is much
lower than it really is
there is this curious distinction made
which most people don't understand
between core inflation and headline
inflation
the core inflation is this is a basic
two percent
target which doesn't matter and the
headline inflation is once you include
all sorts of things like energy prices
and sudden tax rises and the rest
well the inflation rate is skewed they
use all kinds of contrivances to make
the inflation rate look lower than what
it really is
if the us government were using the same
cpi model that they did when president
carter was in the white house in the
late 1970s
the inflation rate today in the united
states would be nine or ten percent
that's how badly the currency is being
debased now the reason why they do that
is there are a lot of inflation-adjusted
responsibilities that the us government
has
to pay out money to you know for example
people on the social security system
on an inflation-adjusted basis if they
keep the
inflation rate low according to their
own statistic that means they're paying
out less that means the government
budget deficit is less
a thriving metropolis toledo is one of
the world's greatest glass processing
centers
in akron the state's fifth largest city
that story deals primarily with rubber
akron is the rubber manufacturing
capital of the nation and the world
her very name is synonymous with rubber
in a global economy where currencies are
measured only against each other
countries are able to artificially lower
the value of their own currency
making their industries more competitive
a country with a weak currency can make
products cheaper
causing entire industrial centers to
move overseas
this effect has been seen countless
times in cities around the world
some of which still haven't recovered
from the loss of their industrial base
i think the guy on the street is he's
kind of frustrated they go
gosh i went to college i don't have a
job i can't get a job
i spent all this money i've got student
loans it's costing me more to live
the fed is telling me there's no
inflation yet i go to the store and i
see the price of milk going up
eggs meat i pull into a gas station it's
costing me more for gas
they don't really understand how all
this affects them on a personal level
and that's why i think they're
frustrated because there isn't
an educational system that explains that
look when you print money
when you have nothing backing in and
when you debase it
you have all the side effects that you
see
higher inflation costs corruption
cronyism
all the things that have been in
headlines that we've seen over the last
four or five years
the protest movements are an interesting
phenomenon
a lot of people are terribly upset with
wall street they're upset what's
happening to their purchasing power
they're upset with the news that they
hear
of the fact that the executives of these
giant banks are getting million dollar
bonuses at the same time
they're dipping into the pockets of the
taxpayers to get all this bailout money
and so they're
angry unfortunately people are
demonstrating against the crisis the
economic crisis
and yet at the same time they're
demanding more welfare
demanding more medical benefits they're
demanding more
state control and regulation of their
lives they're demanding more
money being created and pumped into the
society they don't realize that those
are the very things that have brought
them onto the street in the first place
in their anger
while the person on the street is
struggling to get by
we're told that what we're experiencing
is a typical recession
why then does this current crisis feel
different to previous economic
recessions
this is far from typical i think this is
the end game i think
what we're experiencing now are the
pains of
the 40-year experiment in fiat currency
coming to an end and it is an absolute
failure
not only for america but for the entire
world
up until 2008 we've been borrowing more
and more money to maintain our standard
of living
are we now at the point where we're
maxed out and cannot take on
any more new debt what we're seeing
today is deleveraging
at all levels of society i mean
consumers are maxed out
each succession that we had in the
economy when we went through this boom
and bus
period we'd go through a bust they would
reinflate again
the economy would start up again but we
kept piling on piling on
piling on levels of debt and finally we
reached the point where you just can't
pile any more debt
banks are no longer willing to give out
credit so freely
and many people are more concerned with
paying off existing debt as opposed to
taking on new debt
while this is prudent sensible behavior
it's also a serious threat to the global
economy
having set itself up as a giant ponzi
scheme
the global economy is reliant on more
and
larger debt being issued to keep itself
functioning
if you try to just live within your
means and
uh and get by with just the amount of
dollars that we have today
paying the interest on them collapses
the currency supply and so
we continually have to borrow more units
of currency into existence
every month than we extinguish by paying
off debt
the system as it's been presently
structured is that they have to continue
expanding the money supply otherwise the
system is going to die
politicians and pundits talk about
living within our means
and paying down the debt you can't do
that without collapsing the entire
economy
we would just vanish into this black
hole all the politicians are in a
situation where if they don't come to
the rescue
we could just have an overnight shutdown
which they can't ever imagine happening
while they're in power so there's always
this wish to
to move it on and kick as you know the
expression kick the can down the road
which is really
what we're doing but the problem is
we've run out of road
you know there is no place to kick the
can anymore
we've got to deal with the can and it's
not simply a can because every time we
kicked it down the road
unfortunately it got bigger so now it's
an enormous can
and you know it's going to crush us
while the financial crisis of 2008 may
have been the first death throes of the
ponzi scheme
governments around the world weren't
about to sit back and let it fail
so they delayed the inevitable collapse
pushing it down the road by bailing out
struggling financial institutions
buying toxic mortgages and taking on
debt
on behalf of its citizens
[Music]
in 2009 and 2010 what happened was the
crisis was papered over
through bailouts guarantees money
printing expansion of the money supply
etc governments can do that i mean don't
underestimate the ability of governments
to
dictate results in the short run but in
the long run
none of the problems were solved the bad
debts are still there the banks are
still insolvent
the banks are not landing the economy is
not growing so we haven't really solved
anything
by buying their way out of these crises
by creating money out of nothing and
flooding it into the economy and
diluting the purchasing power
they're not really solving the problem
what they're doing is pushing it off a
little bit into the future
and making it worse now do we keep going
down this road do we print more money i
mean the fed balance sheet went from
800 billion to 3 trillion should it now
go to 6 trillion
we had a 800 billion dollar stimulus
should we now have a
two trillion dollar stimulus i mean in
theory you could
but this is where people could lose
faith entirely in the currency and the
currency could collapse
the federal reserve's money printing
exercises may help prop up the economy
in the short term
but what are the consequences of money
printing on such a large scale
i think you're going to see a very rapid
decline in the value of the dollar
in a matter of days whether it's 20
percent 30 percent 40 percent
a lot of people have been buying the
dollar
as a safe haven you know when they find
out that there's no safety there
in fact they need a safe haven from the
dollar i mean right now the dollar is
benefiting from the fear trade
well what if the fear trade is afraid of
the dollar
aside from causing an enormous amount of
inflation
the federal reserve's reckless money
printing exercises
also run the very real risk of creating
a worldwide loss of confidence in the
u.s dollar
i think a currency crisis is highly
likely but it'll be very difficult to
know exactly what will cause it and when
i think it'll be something unforeseen it
could be a natural disaster it could be
a political shock could be just a
general loss of confidence
it could be something as simple as a
treasury
auction that goes bad there's no buyers
and all of a sudden the interest rate
starts to go up
then the financial players the big hedge
funds start to react to a dump in
dollars
then all of a sudden you have foreign
central banks that begin dumping dollars
get me out
and when that happens just like that at
some point just like all ponzi schemes
the participants wake up to the con they
don't want to participate anymore
and the whole thing implodes now you
know when
private uh factors when people who are
voluntarily
uh participating foreigners foreign
central banks
uh when they stop buying the one
difference is the federal reserve can
come
and supply the demand for the people who
are waking up to the ponzi nature of
what we're doing
but of course when the fed becomes the
only buyer that's the end game
or be the beginning of the
hyperinflation
hyperinflation is a rapid increase in
the inflation rate
so much so that you know people lose
faith in the currency
and you see what is in fact a flight
from the currency
defeated germany as a runaway inflation
in germany the mark becomes so worthless
it is used to paper walls
or the light stoves what happens is the
government spends so much money
forcing it to borrow it gets to the
stage where it's borrowing more money
than the market is willing to lend to it
the central bank then steps in and turns
that government debt into currency
the great question is and i don't know
the answer
is that what level of inflation 5 10
15 20 percent do start to panic
all i know is when that level comes
everybody panics together
consequence of a hyperinflation is the
price of goods and services rises very
very rapidly
and that feeds upon itself causing
people to get rid of the currency
even more quickly so you then have a
situation where
people go out and they buy things just
to get the hell out of paper money
and paradoxically that then starts
driving an accelerating demand for paper
money because they want more paper money
to go and buy
things so you have the situation where
the value of paper money starts
collapsing
in advance of this issue in everyday
life you'll be
scrambling from day to day to get
tangible things
if you're thinking of buying one can of
tuna you're going to buy two
because you know that tomorrow or even
later on that day or the next hour that
can of tunas can be costing you more
that you're going to be scrambling to
get anything that's tangible
this period is going to involve a lot of
economic pain
a lot of people who are currently
retired in america
are going to have to get jobs their
retirement is gone it's it's been
bankrupted because they put their faith
in a bernie madoff type uh national
ponzi scheme
and of course a lot of the property is
going to
decay if people are spending money on
these necessities
they don't have money to make the
repairs necessary to maintain their
properties
if the landlords can't collect rents
from their tenants how are they going to
maintain the properties
how are they going to pay the taxes so i
think the whole
economy is going to crumble beneath the
weight of this runaway inflation
and of course uh the initial reaction by
the fed will be to
create even more inflation to try to
stimulate the economy by printing even
more money
which of course is the source of the
problem
on the surface it would appear that this
is a problem
facing the united states alone but with
so many countries
holding their savings in u.s government
bonds
a loss of confidence in the u.s dollar
could trigger a global crisis
which would affect every nation on earth
if the us dollar hyperinflates the
implications are
really profound because you can go to a
country like zimbabwe and see the impact
of a hyperinflation but what happens
when the world's reserve currency
hyperinflates we've never been in this
situation
before it's impossible to predict you
know what the outcome is going to be
but logic suggests that if the us dollar
hyperinflates
most if not all of the currencies of the
world will also have severe economic
problems because at the end of the day
the reserves of all of these currencies
are basically dollars
[Music]
there have been dozens and dozens of
currency collapses since the end of the
second world war
and they all result from the same thing
you know bad policies bad management
and the us right now is pursuing bad
policies central bank is doing a bad job
managing the currency
as a consequence it's inevitable that
the dollar is going to collapse
it's on this road that i call the fiat
currency graveyard
the markets the private sector however
you like to decide it people
they suddenly sort of move in a herd
instinct they suddenly sort of
understand things
and this can happen overnight i mean it
really can so the timing of this is
i think very difficult if anything
impossible for us to say but i would
point out that there is the danger that
i use a metaphor one morning we will
wake up and find that we are in a very
different world
it may not be one morning it may be a
week a month
i don't know but when it happens i think
it'll happen quite quickly and we won't
really be able to predict when
hyperinflation may be one of several
scenarios facing the world today
but history has shown us that whenever a
nation tried to run its economy
using an artificial fiat system the end
result is always the same
disaster there is a proven
100 percent failure rate there is no
exception to this
fiat currencies always fail and then 40
years ago
we tried this grand experiment where all
the world's currencies became fiat at
the same time
when we ended the bretton woods system
the world is going to have to extricate
itself
from this monetary system based on the
dollar because if you want to back your
currency you have to back it with
something
you can't back it with nothing you
always think of that old superman movie
where
the first one where lois lane you know
she falls off the top of the
the building and superman catches her
and he says i got you don't worry i got
you
and she said well you got me who's got
you well that's the dollar who's got the
dollar it's not superman
the dollar can't fly on its own the
dollar used to be backed by gold
it was gold that had the dollar it's
like everybody has tethered their ships
to the titanic of currencies and so
we're all going to go down
if there is a loss of confidence in the
us dollar and i think there will be in
this decade
it's happened before it'll just be
history repeating
then we'll probably have to go back to
something that will instill confidence
and what instills confidence is gold
the only real solution is to go back to
a real sound
currency real money with something
behind it
doesn't have to be gold or silver but
historically that has always been
what societies have chosen through trial
and error they've tried this they've
tried that
they always wind up with gold or silver
i think that probably is a clue that
not a bad way to go with all the
uncertainty facing the world today
a return to a gold-backed economy would
seem logical
so how come there isn't so much as a
discussion about such a return
the answer is as simple as it is
alarming
the people at the top the ones who have
been benefiting from the current ponzi
system
don't want the ride to end many now
believe
the price of gold and silver have been
artificially suppressed
to make it seem less desirable as a unit
of global exchange
what governments try to do is to
maintain
a low gold price because by doing that
it makes the dollar look worthy of being
the world's reserve currency when in
fact we know
the dollar is not worthy of that
esteemed position because it's being so
badly mismanaged by the united states
groups like the gold anti-trust action
committee or gata
have been tracking what they believe is
the deliberate suppression of gold and
silver prices through a variety of
dubious means
in 12 years we've amassed nothing but
evidence
that supports the manipulation of gold
price but it's be like talking about a
murder trial
when the jury would say guilty beyond a
reasonable doubt but you know you've got
to
present each point of evidence and how
it all fits together there are numerous
methods that they use to suppress the
price of gold
some are harder to prove than others but
some of them are fully reported and
that's central bank sales
between 1999 and 2002
the bank of england foolishly sold a
massive amount of britain's gold
reserves
at an average price of 275 dollars an
ounce
the proceeds were spent buying euros and
u.s dollars
the governments of canada france and
switzerland
among others were also sellers of their
gold around this time
we know that the central banks used to
sell 400 tons every year well why were
they selling 400 tons
obviously it was the dumbest decision
anyone could have made in the decade
by far the dumbest but they did it every
year sell 400 it's all 400
i mean now you know gold goes from 300
to 1600 almost 17 or why were you
selling the gold
because they were trying to keep the
price down so it was a coordinated thing
to keep everyone focused on believing in
currencies
alan greenspan in testimony to congress
admitted
that they were manipulating the price of
gold when he said
the world's central banks stand ready to
lease gold in
increasing quantities meaning they were
already doing it
should the price of gold rise meaning
the target was to suppress the price of
gold
so they were already doing it and their
target was to suppress the price of gold
he admitted it in testimony to congress
although central banks are able to sell
off their country's gold holdings
legally
they may have also been suppressing the
price of gold using some other
rather questionable means some
investigators believe that western
central banks have been loaning their
country's gold to bullion banks
a bullion bank is an institution that
sells gold with the intention of buying
it back
sometime in the future at a cheaper
price
with the proceeds of this sale these
banks have been known to buy u.s
government bonds while this isn't a
problem in itself
central banks report the gold they have
and the gold they've loaned to these
bullion banks
as one item so while a central bank may
claim it has a certain amount of gold in
reserves
much of that gold may be on loan to a
bullion bank
which may have sold the gold in exchange
for government bonds
one means of intervention in the goat
market is
the lending of gold to so-called bullion
banks and they
sell it in the market this is suppresses
the price as
if the central banks would sell it
directly but
this landing does not appear in the book
of the central banks
the u.s treasury a few years ago changed
the way they account for gold and
they're
accounting for some of their receivables
and their inventory as one line item
so they're accounting for what they
actually have and what people owe them
as the same thing and that is basically
illegal accounting
it's fraudulent but why work so
hard to keep the price of gold and
silver low
why do healthy gold and silver prices
threaten to collapse the ponzi scheme
there's this competitive relationship
between gold
and national currencies because gold is
the only competitor
to a national currency you know gold is
money and these national currencies are
money substitutes
that circulate in place of gold fiat
money gives the power to government
real money keeps the power with the
people because when you have real money
government is limited it can only spend
what it taxes
and the public will resist taxation but
if the government can simply print and
borrow there's a lot less resistance and
so it's a lot easier
for the government to grow when it can
promise something for nothing
and so that's what they do and so gold
is what protects the people
from the reckless policies of government
gold is government chaperone
the government wants to be able to do
whatever it wants gold stands in its way
so
yes gold is an enemy a big government
but it's a friend of freedom it's a
protector of individuals
from government gold's a competitor to
the dollar
when it's going way up it's a threat for
inflation it's a barometer of the
well-being of the isaac look at gold
screaming now and the world's falling
apart
so it calls attention to how bad things
are so the us government
has an interest wall street the
politicians
to keep the price suppressed wall street
doesn't want you going down to
a coin dealer buying gold and silver
coins
they want to sell you paper the
government wants to sell your paper so i
would say it's the government and wall
street
gold in the hands of people is the way
you control government
governments cannot create money out of
thin air if it's gold
they can only create paper out of thin
air and if they can create paper out of
thin air they can use that
paper to wage wars or they can use that
paper as a political contrivance to
enrich
their friends and as a consequence
governments have been fighting gold all
century long
despite this desire to keep gold and
silver down
the recent instability in the markets
has seen the demand for gold and silver
skyrocket this in turn has exposed a
deeper problem within the central banks
the problem the central banks in the
west now face
is that they have sold an awful lot of
gold to try and suppress the price of
gold
they are now embarrassed by the fact
that central banks
not in that original cartel are now
really
very keen buyers of gold and we're
talking about the chinese we're talking
about the russians talking about the
indians
we're talking about even mexico all
these
non-mainstream central banks not part of
if you like the top
club members of the bank of
international settlements
you know the little guys in that context
they're picking up hundreds of tons of
the stuff
to suppress the price of gold western
central banks have had to sell
or loan out their country's gold
holdings but
because the gold they sell rarely leaves
their vaults
no one can be certain they aren't
selling or loaning out more
gold than they physically own if this is
true
then this could be one of the biggest
scams ever perpetrated in history
a massive con perpetrated not by
individuals but by
entire governments this central bank
gold
most of it sits at the new york federal
reserve and the bank of england so it's
in the basement of these two places and
it doesn't actually move when a country
is doing international settlement they
basically take a bar off of this pile
and put it on that pile
or they'll just change the labels or
it's just a book entry it's accounting
except there's been some pretty creative
accounting on all this gold
and i doubt very much that
i don't think all of it is there the
question
remains if everybody especially the big
players
who wanted all of their gold delivered
at the same time
it is physically impossible to do it
most gold that exists on the planet
there's more than one claim
on each ounce of gold there's several
people that think that they have titled
that same ounce of gold
i am have said many many many times over
and over again
if you can't hold it you don't own it
the game can't go on forever because
sooner or later
people are going to demand their
physical gold or silver and that already
is happening
the lack of accountability in gold sales
by western central banks
hasn't been a concern so far but as more
and more buyers of gold have started to
demand
physical delivery central banks that
have oversold or
loaned out their country's gold will
find themselves caught in a major
scandal
the result of such fraudulent activity
means buyers of gold
be they individuals pension or hedge
funds or even
entire nations could be ripped off for
billions of dollars it's a little
similar than the murdoch scandal here at
fox news in london
of the made off scandal i mean
the it's a very incestuous relationship
between press
big money and the politicians and
unfortunately these things don't get
correct until they blow up
madoff blew up murdoch blew up the gold
market is going to blow up and i think
will be a bigger scandal
than either of them because it's a
worldwide financial situation
[Music]
the only trick that the politicians in
power today know
and the central banker the only trick
they know is to create more money out of
nothing to inflate the currency they
have no other trick
so as long as we keep looking to them
to be our leaders and solve the problem
that
how can we expect anything else that's
the only trick they know
because the only trick the other trick
there is
is to stop inflating and to go back to a
sound currency and that would say
they say oh no we can't do that and the
reason they can't do that is because it
would put them all out of business
they wouldn't be able to continue the
ponzi scheme
even with cracks forming in the current
financial system
the only solutions offered by
governments
are in fact just more steps down the
road to disaster
but while a single person may not be
able to save the world
there is still something you can do to
protect your family
and yourself you cannot turn
to a ponzi schemer and ask him to do
to run a real business because he
doesn't know how
so you can't turn to all of these ponzi
schemers in government
who are inflating the currency and say
well let's solve the crisis
in some other way because they don't
know how so the solution is to quit
depending on the same people with the
same mentality
to solve our problems if governments
won't go back on a gold standard
individuals can go back on the gold
standard all by themselves politicians
can create
fiat money at will that's why it's fiat
so
why would you want to put your faith in
that
put your trust in politicians and
bureaucrats and central bankers
when you can just have something real
that has intrinsic value that is scarce
and that is going to remain scarce would
you rather have gold or a fiat currency
and we see what's happening in the world
and obviously people are
starting to figure out that gold is is
was likely to sustain its value
way more than a piece of paper is it's
not that the price of gold is going
up is that the value of the dollar is
going down the price remains constant in
terms of
human effort and purchasing power an
ounce of gold today
will buy the same thing it bought 2 000
years ago
an ounce of gold today is approximately
takes so much human effort to get out
and refine
the same human effort that it took to do
certain things 2000 years ago it's the
human effort equation
that maintains stability how much effort
does it take
gold is financial insurance
and the thing about it is you own it
because you want to be protected and
you know you just have to have it if you
want to have or sleep at night because
there's nothing else
you know if some catastrophic event
happens and we've seen them
how are you going to be protected
the current financial system may be
dying but where there is chaos
there is also opportunity as the old
model falls apart
the door may be opened for great
prosperity
it's clearly not the end of the world
it's probably not even the end of
america
for many countries this is going to be
the beginning of
an economic boom a giant burden being
lifting off their shoulders
where the world no longer has to loan
trillions of dollars to americans so
that we can continue to consume
what we don't produce when this comes to
an end
the world will benefit so it is not
something that we should
fear we should embrace it as a world
this is the greatest wealth transfer in
history
if we have a global currency crisis
then you're going to see a greater
wealth transfer than has ever happened
in
all of history it's all going to happen
at once
therefore it's the greatest opportunity
we have millions of people now
taking an interest in what is money the
question of what is money
what should it be and they're learning
especially a lot of young people
the sun will rise tomorrow as it has a
million times before
commuters will wake up and travel to
their offices to begin the day's work
farmers will tend to their crops and
construction workers will build new
infrastructure
but will the world they live in still be
the same
in 2008 the world was given a wake-up
call
the biggest financial crash in human
history was delayed by the same poor
decisions that brought it about in the
first place
what that massive bailout bought us was
not a solution
but merely time time for the people
responsible to ring the last few dollars
out of a dying system
but also for those able to see the cliff
edge approaching
time to protect themselves and their
families from the imminent plunge
and in the end that time may prove to be
the most valuable commodity of all
there are these brief moments in history
where the
safe haven asset for the last 5 000
years
simultaneously becomes the asset class
that has the greatest single
potential gains in purchasing power
we're in one of these cycles right now
where money is the best investment
[Music]
get out of currency buy money and you're
probably going to be able to buy a whole
lot more stuff
later
but the best thing that people can do of
all is really to
take on their own responsibility for
getting financially educated
this is the most important thing don't
let
the banks and the brokerage houses and
other people guide all of your decisions
find out what's going on for yourself
empower yourself
you